- ♪ Saving earth from space ♪
♪ Power Falcons! ♪
- [roars]
[falcon screech]
[growls]
- Yellow Falcon,
what do your senses tell ya?
- Destructo is
a killing machine.
- [growls]
- His armor is impervious
to our blasters.
You got any ideas,
Red Falcon?
- Sure do, Yellow Falcon.
Blue Falcon, you remember
our battle at Dango Bluff?
I'll take the legs,
you take the blasters.
- It was Beaver Creek,
and I took the legs.
Make sure you shore up
that flank, Black Falcon.
- Um, are you talking to me?
Because I'm
the Green Falcon.
- No time for that,
Black Falcon.
Purple Falcon,
arm missiles!
- Roger that.
Arming missiles now.
[machinery whirring]
- Uh--
- Battle formations.
We're going in.
- Hey.
- Roger that.
- Hold up.
- Copy that.
- Roger.
- My falcon is green.
- Hey, hey, hey.
We can talk about
our falcon colors when we get
back to base, Black Falcon.
Right now,
we got a mission to do.
Fall into falcon formation.
[screaming, explosion]
- Well, now, here's the issue
is that, you're gonna
give me an order, I'm not gonna
know you're talking to me.
'cause...i'm not
in a Black Falcon.
- Come on, chill it out,
Black Falcon.
- Yeah, Black Falcon ,
relax.
- First of all,
I don't like the way
you guys are saying "black."
Second of all,
there is no Black Falcon!
I'm Green Falcon!
- Black Falcon, homie,
no one's trying to get up
in your grill here.
- Uh-uh, uh-uh, uh-uh.
Don't talk to me like that.
No, don't say "grill"
like that.
I'm the Green Falcon ,
and i--
- Oh, stop being
so Black Falcon about it.
- What the [bleep]
do you mean by that?
- Black Falcon, brother,
I understand
what you're going through.
- Do you?
No, I don't think you do.
How would you feel if
I called you Red Falcon , huh?
- Whoa!
- and Purple Falcon,
how would you feel if I called
you Yellow Falcon, huh?
- That's racist.
- That was racist.
- Yeah, that's racist.
- Ooh, that is racist.
- That's racist?
Oh, see, okay, nope, forget it.
Black Falcon out--
Green Falcon!
[whoosh]
Green Falcon! Damn it!
- Hey! Why'd that Green Falcon
fall out of falcon formation?
Black Falcon,
get on that and report back.
Black Falcon?
Black Falcon, come in.
[rock music]
- ♪ Saving earth from space ♪
♪ Power Falcons! ♪